well Donald Trump appears to have
admitted to a major crime during his
latest childish tantrum insane meltdown
the equivalent of I don't know a little
kid pooping in the sandbox because it's
time to go home Donald Trump has now
alleged that he helped Ron DeSantis in
his 2018 election
by sending in the FBI
to do what it's not even clear clearly
some kind of election interference this
you absolutely have to see Trump posting
on his platform truth social
12th Central quote I also fixed his
campaign
which had completely Fallen apart I was
all in for Ron and he beat Gillum but
after the race race is capitalized we
don't know why you never know why but
after the race when votes were being
stolen by the corrupt capital E election
process in Broward County and Ron was
going down 10 000 votes a day along with
now Senator Rick Scott
I sent in the FBI and the U.S attorneys
and the ballot theft immediately ended
just prior to them running out of the
votes necessary to win I stopped his
election from being stolen
Trump did what
Trump sent in the FBI
to to do what to stop ballots from being
counted ballots which were increasingly
going for Andrew Gillum Trump is either
casually admitting to using federal
agencies to interfere in a state
election or for some reason he's making
it up and lying about it which makes him
even more depraved and unhinged which
one do you think that it is how is this
an allegation that the Department of
Justice doesn't follow up on using
federal agencies to interfere with the
state election that you see is turning
against the way you want it to go is it
to stop the ballot Counting is it to
ensure only certain ballots are counted
what is it that Trump is even claiming
that he did and even if the scenario is
Trump's lying and making this up there's
almost always a grain of Truth to some
of these things what did Donald Trump do
we have no idea but he appears to be
admitting to criminality now there's
another aspect to this that's important
to consider as well
notice that
when it comes to the search warrant at
Mar-A-Lago I know some of you know
exactly where I'm going with this with
the Mar-A-Lago search warrant
Trump's criticism and the criticism of
Steve Bannon and Hannity and you know
all these people the criticism is
the Biden Administration is using the
FBI
as a political tool the Biden
Administration is politicizing and
weaponizing what's supposed to be a law
enforcement agency
it doesn't appear that that's what's
happening everything was done 100
correctly when it comes to the search
warrant
but what Donald Trump is saying is I'm
actually the one who did it I
politically used the FBI
to go into Florida and I I guess he's
saying to stop the vet the vote count
that was turning in Andrew gillum's
favor
it is insane the degree to which these
allegations end up being confessions
this one just took a little while when
it came to
summer of 2020. they are going to try to
steal an election they don't win talking
about Democrats well within just a
couple months we figured out oh Trump
was going to try to steal an election
that he didn't actually win the
allegation was a confession about what
they were going to do and there's been
numerous examples of this oh Hillary
Clinton isn't going to safeguard and
properly handle classified and sensitive
documents well it took a few years but
we figured out oh actually it's Trump
who wasn't going to safeguard and
seriously handle those documents we that
allegation was also a confession and now
since Joe Biden became president and in
particular since the search warrant was
executed at Mar-A-Lago oh this is a this
is a presidency that is politicizing and
weaponizing the FBI against political
opponents
Trump seems to be admitting to having
done exactly that
in favor of his then Ally Rhonda Santos
and against the uh political opponent
Andrew Gillum another allegation which
appears to be a confession or Trump is
just lying about the fact that he
committed a crime if Trump did this it
is illegal the David packman shows
longest running sponsor is blinkist the
app that takes thousands of non-fiction
books boils each of them down into an
explainer you can read or listen to in
15 minutes blinkist also condenses
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers I've been using
blinkist for years to supplement the
books I read I love reading I I read all
the time but there's even more books I
don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com davidpakman
the link is down below